la mia idea che voglio condividere con
voi ho un'idea che son certo già
condividiamo e son certo che ognuno di
noi tutti noi si siederanno nel
solitario più o meno una volta al giorno
e ci rifletteranno su per vedere questo
da un'altra prospettiva
fabrizio de andrè beh anche questa idea
bello condividere
cosa condividiamo con fabrizio de andrè
io personalmente condivido
un'idea che la bellezza non nasce dalla
materia primissima che la bellezza di
interesse la passione può nascere da una
materia seconda da un usato dalle tarme
nascono i fior bellezza nel nostro caso
è intesa come materia come recupero per
fabrizio de andrè cantava anche in via
del campo ci vanno un illuso e quanto
spero di evitare di formazione sono un
ingegnere lavoro con un cani con i
contaminanti al dipartimento di
biotecnologie sono stato contaminato
dalle biotecnologie e tendo a pensare
alla sostenibilità tecnica ambientale ma
anche economica quindi partiamo dal
concetto di sostenibilità
partiamo un po dei massimi sistemi
permettetelo qui e il posto giusto per
parlare di questi temi la sostenibilità
si basa come concetto del primo ministro
norvegese degli anni 90 sulle famose tre
p tre i tre pilastri che l'ars che sono
planet people profit l'intersezione
omogenea di queste tre p dovrebbe
portare al concetto di sviluppo
sostenibile
questo concetto di sviluppo sostenibile
come si è tradotto
se pensiamo allo sviluppo reale ancora
tecnico ed economico
vediamo che il modello cambia ed è un
modello che forse ci ricorda cosa scelgo
da mickey mouse
questo è il modello di sviluppo che
attualmente abbiamo dove lapidi profit
fa da locomotiva e plan and the people
sono accessori spesso utilizzati per
immagine per marketing efficaci senza
dubbio ma sicuramente non sono i
propulsori dell'economia dello sviluppo
bene questo ha delle conseguenze e 19
agosto 2014
molti di noi erano in ferie mare
montagne ovunque o comunque stavamo
riposando ci stavamo godendoci le nostre
vacanze estive negli ultimi anni in
agosto ca di un giorno molto importante
e l'over su dei giudei è un giorno in
cui noi con il nostro piedone abbiamo
superato impronta ecologica anche la
nostra terra ci riserva in modo
rinnovabile con il nostro piedone il 19
agosto abbiamo iniziato a rosicchiare le
risorse che sono dei nostri figli
oggi servirebbero circa due pianeti
se noi continuassimo tutta la
popolazione mondiale a vivere con il suo
tenore per soddisfare i nostri bisogni
non solo se vivessimo tutti con il
tenore con l'approccio dei nordamericani
ne servirebbero 3.44 e servendo circa
quattro pianeti e via giù non europei
viviamo con un pedone che 2.5 volte più
grande delle risorse che tenete a mente
a disposizione attenzione a questo
grafico nell'asse delle ascisse vedete è
la popolazione i forti cambiamenti che
sono in atto nell'economia globale
vedono il nostro piedoni inganni si
sempre di più il classico esempio in cui
in piedi di un elefante schiaccia una
mosca
per tutte queste sono riflessioni che
noi scienziati che ci occupiamo di
tecniche sostenibili
ci poniamo sempre e le conclusioni
spesso sono chiare
stiamo distruggendo il pianeta
probabilmente ma dobbiamo evitare
assolutamente tutti gli ismi dobbiamo
notare il terrorismo ambientale gli
ecologismi dobbiamo essere chiari in
quelle che troviamo è quando ci chiedono
di riff rasare i nostri pensieri
dobbiamo pensare un approccio
scientifico in modo da provare risultati
e da provare che non suo piedone tanto
più grande di quello che offerto da
circa due mesi mi è cambiata la vita
perché due amici ha avuto il mio primo
figlio che penso abbia già capito il
messaggio
noi stiamo soddisfacendo i nostri
bisogni compromettendo i suoi bisogni
vi assicuro che da quando sono diventato
padre nel profondo
penso a questi temi perché quando
pensiamo i cambiamenti climatici
all'ambiente pensiamo a un ambiente bene
comune che però è più grande di noi e
quando penso a mio figlio pensò bene di
posso garantire se mi impegno un'ottima
educazione di posso garantire un futuro
economia soldi va bene ma vi posso
garantire uno sviluppo sostenibile
posso davanti del suo ambiente per il
futuro beh il mio compito e disseminare
queste informazioni
ovviamente lavorarci nel mio ma far sì
che tutti si rendano coscienti di quale
può essere un approccio affinché loro e
noi stessi del nostro futuro
abbiamo un pedone che è ridimensionato
che diventa almeno dell'impronta del
nostro pianeta
quale può essere una possibile soluzione
una soluzione può essere quella di
passare da un approccio economico
lineare che quello ci ha sempre
contraddistinto noi pensiamo di essere
un punto in una linea
prendiamo risorse facciamo i nostri
prodotti che utilizziamo quando questi
prodotti non sono più utilizzabili gli
smaltiamo questi diventano rifiuti
siamo un punto in questa linea che porta
all
credo neanche s'ingrossa ma una linea
non è dove noi siamo collocati noi
dovremmo essere collocati noi dovremmo
essere punto in un cerchio la nostra
economia di lineare dovrebbe diventare
economia circolare e questo ci
permetterebbe anche di avere vantaggi
competitivi pensando alle nostre
attitudini ai nostri prodotti con un
approccio che possa prendere risorse
creare prodotti pensandoli già il con
una mentalità di eco design ovvero già
pensando li progettandoli in modo che
quando noi dobbiamo progettare sapremo
come smontarli e recuperare risorse
questo si può fare in ambito bio e
quello che noi facciamo all'università
di verona si può fare in ambito hard
quando pensiamo ai nostri prodotti e
quindi pensiamo a comprendere metalli
utilizzarli e come poterli recuperare
questi cerchi che abbiamo in testa
questi circoli devono essere realizzati
sempre da un punto di vista globale in
tanti progetti che noi vediamo in tante
idee e tanti articoli vediamo sempre i
calcoli economici calcoli finanziari
questo non è sviluppo sostenibile non è
intersezione delle tre p bene io mi
occupo di acque reflue
mi occupo di acqua per me l'acqua si
questa quando la bevo ma per me l'acqua
non è l'idea di rubinetto per me l'acqua
è un'altra idea per me l'acqua non e blu
per me l'acqua e marrone e il tema di
quest'anno è oltre il muro vorrei andare
oltre il muro e parlarvi di acqua già
pensiero di moore e acqua ci fa capire
come un muro non può tenere l'acqua e
quindi volevo farvi vedere questo muro
un attimo vado oltre il muro a prendere
il nostro muro e questo è il peso della
scienza
volevo ringraziare gli organizzatori
perché mi hanno procurato questo settore
non mi importa il design il contenitore
non ci interessa ci interessa il
contenuto ed effettivamente design non è
male anche in questo caso
beh quando noi pensiamo a questo magic
box alonso amico toilet pensiamo tutto
quello che ci buttiamo dentro
pensiamo a le migliaia di molecole che
sono sintetizzate perderà il nostro
sviluppo e per noi questo è un bel muro
dove titolo ciaccone e via tutto viene
mangiato male immagino così io una volta
che tira lo sciacquone tutto scompare il
muro mi permette di non vedere quello
che oltre e pensate solo a che
disperazione ci prende quando lo
sciacquone non funziona bene
diventiamo matti vai o chiamò la polizia
pensate quando quello che noi
scarichiamo di cui ci vogliamo
dimenticare va oltre il nostro muro e
quindi rimane alla nostra vista bene
ricordate noi siamo parte di un cerchio
un cerchio non ai muri perché comunque
possa raggiungere la parte che oltre al
muro
a fronte di questo parlar di acqua
significa parlare di un cerchio l'acqua
non è un tubo né una linea l'acqua e
circolare il ciclo dell'acqua
parlando della corban a parte dalla
captazione poi c'è il tubo che porta ad
un impianto di trattamento dove
l'impianto di trattamento significa
impianto biochimico poi passò allo
scarico è il mio obiettivo è quello di
scaricare in modo che sia accettabile
dal corpo d'acqua come è fatto un
impianto di trattamento
eccolo qui a questi sono particolarmente
vicino perché ho iniziato il mio
dottorato in questo impianto annunciate
mio dottorato già oltre il muro dei
laboratori noi ricercatori spesso siamo
fuori dai laboratori lasciamo be on the
wall e come funziona l'impianto subito
rimuoviamo il materiale grossolano
pensate solo a quanta cellulose posso
recuperare quanta carta igienica possa
recuperare poi tutto va a questa vasca
centrale che una grossa vasca biologico
un gran pentolone
dei microrganismi che è disponibile
ovunque nord nei paesi ad esempio per i
paesi del nord del mondo
l'obiettivo è quello di creare un
influente che sia depurato liberato
dagli inquinanti
bene questo è l'approccio che
attualmente stiamo seguendo ma è un
approccio che comporta consumo di
energia che comporta una grossa carbon
footprint non è carbon neutral come il
nostro telex prendete il vostro libretto
e vedete che questo tedeschi stato
realizzato in modo da essere carbon
neutral
l'obiettivo che dobbiamo porci è quindi
quello di andare oltre questo concetto è
far diventare il nostro depuratore una
fabbrica di risorse una fabbrica di
risorse che può portare alla boutique
del vc alle risorse che io posso
recuperare dal nostro voce
parliamo ad esempio di nutrienti tutto
quello che vedete qui è recuperato dalla
cacca dei veronesi di fatto partiamo dal
fosforo
eccolo qui il fosforo una risorsa che ha
tra 50 anni finirà le risorse
rinnovabili
ho fatto due conti 50 nel 36 86 caspita
riguarda anche me e quindi abbiamo
iniziato a studiare il fosforo come
recuperare fertilizzanti risorse che le
cui miniere si stanno esaurendo più
velocemente del petrolio e pochi lo
sanno quando questo è un nutriente che
sta scomparendo possiamo recuperare
energia come recuperar gas scusate
questo non potevo chiuderlo perché
parliamo di idrogeno parliamo di metano
come recuperare acque per il riutilizzo
ma come recuperare anche molecole ad
elevato valore aggiunto
partendo da questo concetto partendo dal
concetto che il nostro depuratore può
diventare una bio raffineria basata
sulle acque reflue una bio raffineria da
cui creare nuovi prodotti sulla base dei
nostri scarti partendo da che tipo di
approccio scientifico dall'approccio che
tutto e ovunque e l'ambiente seleziona
ovvero l'approccio della macrobio
community engineering ingegneria delle
comunità microbiche come funziona questa
bene facciamo un esempio parliamo
di quello che forse già resi piuttosto
nodi ultimamente in recupero di bio
plastiche dalle acque reflue
grazie per avermi le tornate veronesi
anch'io ho contribuito quindi grazie a
tutti noi
bene noi da cosa partiamo non partiamo
da un centro puro perché se tu prenditi
pure fi biotecnologie industriali questo
appena lo metti nei rifiuti
scompare partiamo da quel pentolone che
tutti abbiamo a disposizione
applichiamo pressioni selettive
il nostro obiettivo non è di selezionare
un ceppo che faccia il suo lavoro in
quei pentoloni c'è è presente tutto
quello che noi vogliamo in questo caso
l'obiettivo di selezionare dei batteri
che il regime di iper nutrizione siano
capaci come noi tocchiamo il grasso loro
stoccano poli trossi alkhanov ati questo
nome così difficile ovvero un
biopolimero che può avere differenti
utilizzi quelli partendo dai nostri
depuratori in dei bireattori
selezioniamo soprattutto questi batteri
maniera non sterile e alimentando
rifiuti non alimentando food o feed
selezionando una biomassa e capace di
produrre questi prodotti lavorandola
infioratori ed estraendo siamo capaci di
avere bio plastiche da scarti da acque
reflue
in questo modo andiamo a ridurre
l'impronta della nostra depurazione
andiamo a far sì che il nostro
depuratore di 20 energy neutra o energy
positiv carbon neutral o carbon positivo
ma non possono far questo una volta che
estremi più polimeni partendo vedete dal
depuratore
estraggo seleziono dei ceppi che sono
già all'interno del depuratore e da
questo tipo di polimeri opposto produrre
bio plastiche posso produrre
biocarburanti posso produrre molecole ad
alto valore aggiunto
bene il mio depuratore i nostri scarti è
diventato una bio raffineria e tutti noi
siamo produttori di petrolio
di fatto il nostro petrolio sono i
nostri scarti per a fronte di questo
vedrete bravo perfetto ma
l'acqua è un tema globale pensate anche
passato dagli obiettivi del millennio
agli obiettivi sostenibili
dopo il meeting di rio l'obiettivo da
cui siamo più distanti e quello dei
sistemi sanitari per tutti ovvero siamo
molto vicini ad avere acqua potabile per
tutti ma dei sistemi sanitari
siamo lontanissimi pensate che 2.5
miliardi di persone ad oggi non hanno
accesso sistemi sanitari con tutte le
conseguenze ambientali sanitarie ed
economiche che questo a molti conoscono
il world water day meno conoscono il
world toilet dei il nostro amico qui è
un protagonista
ultimamente ma rischiate la vostra vita
senza un fucile immaginate diventeremo
matti probabilmente quindi qual è
l'obiettivo l'obiettivo è di pensare
all'economia globale che a luoghi e
tempi diversi in modo da avere una
economia circolare low cost e ad esempio
in tutti queste zone che non hanno
sistemi sanitari attuali pensarli già in
un'ottica circolare ovvero fare una
bella raccolta differenziata nel vc
separare le urine che se non ricche in
nutrienti e le feci che possono essere
dopo trattamenti utilizzate come
ammendante per recuperare risorse
beh grazie a questo approccio in tutto
il mondo potremmo probabilmente dall'età
me far nascere fiori io vi ringrazio
adesso devo andare grazie